[Musique]
bien nous allons aborder maintenant
l'histoire criminelle de Versailles avec
Hélène Chaabani bonjour bonjour vous
êtes conférencière à l'office du
tourisme de Versailles et alors vous
faites des conférences qui s'institue
ainsi de la faire des poisons sous Louis
XIV à la faire Landru au 20e siècle
revivez les affaires criminelles qui ont
secoué Versailles alors donc vous faites
promener les gens de Versailles ou les
arrêter en leur disant attention
on va en parler mais figurez-vous que
l'autru est là je le vois vous le voyez
en face bonjour Henri désiré bonjour à
vous Patrice
à peu près un siècle après votre mort
vous avez été condamné à Mauricie
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de revenir
sur les traces de l'endroit où vous avez
été jugé un petit peu de mélancolie on
va pas se mentir mélancolie avec un peu
d'amertume ce que c'est quand même là
que j'ai perdu la tête donc c'est
compliqué comme situation honnête là
avec vous en tout cas alors vous êtes
vous êtes en réalité goûter je repars et
vous êtes dans je n'ai rien à vous dire
la pièce général à vous dire l'acteur
qui joue qui joue l'andru là vous n'êtes
pas encore le tout à fait le look et il
y a deux heures un peu plus de 2 heures
de maquillage c'est ça à peu près une de
deux heures deux heures et quart en
fonction des retouches mais voilà je
n'ai pas encore
qui va être plus noir
on va on va reparler dans un de faire
Landru et de la pièce surtout qui va
être captée ici dans ce dans ce tribunal
puisque c'est dans ce tribunal c'est pas
dans cette salle exactement parce que la
salle n'existe plus mais c'est dans ce
tribunal que que l'autre rue a été jugé
mais d'abord on va parler de Versailles
des faits divers alors
vous promenez comme ça les gens alors il
y aura des visites je crois qu'il y a de
la prochaine c'est du 8 octobre et
ensuite le 17 décembre et le 17 on
s'inscrit à l'Office de Tourisme ont
lieu l'après-midi à partir de 15h et
comme on le dit souvent c'est une autre
manière de visiter Versailles puisque
voilà on s'attend Versailles le château
la féérie le décorum et à l'envers du
décor et oui enquête est faits divers il
s'est passé des choses un peu étranges
un peu monstrueuse mais qui permet quand
même d'évoquer l'évolution de la justice
et de la police c'est aussi là l'idée de
faire de l'histoire de l'histoire de
l'art de l'anthropologie de la
sociologie au travers de ces thématiques
fort passionnantes et qui attire
beaucoup de public en fait
c'est un lieu de pouvoir et souvent le
pouvoir le crime sont liés et et il y a
une affaire évidemment dont vous parlez
vous mettez de me dire où est-ce que
vous en parlez dans Versailles c'est la
faire des poisons oui tout à fait alors
un Villier avec avec une affaire ou
habituellement on moque on manque de
condamné on manque de gens et ben là on
en a eu beaucoup trop c'est à dire en
effet je vais reprendre en quelques mots
en quelques phrases la faire des poisons
si toutefois c'est possible parce que
c'est une affaire que je vais qualifier
d'européenne même si à l'époque on ne
peut pas parler de l'Europe actuelle
mais on se rend compte que les choses
donc on va arrêter je vous le fais court
mais on va arrêter 300 personnes j'ai pu
les chiffres exacts mais je crois qu'il
y a un peu moins d'une centaine de
condamnation il y aura des envois en
galère et voilà c'est c'est et ça touche
le les personnes extrêmement proches du
roi alors ça commence comment ça
commence
il y a beaucoup de morts alors vous
allez dire alors il y a un mort qui est
un avant de la marque
Sainte-Croix mais lui il meurt demain de
manière tout à fait naturelle sauf
qu'autour qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve on
retrouve plein de fioles et on se rend
compte qu'on peut tuer sans laisser
aucune trace et puis en fouillant un
petit peu qu'est-ce que l'on retrouve
d'autres des éléments des lettres et
notamment la marquise de Brinvilliers
qui s'accuse de tout un tas de choses
elle n'a pas attendu la mort de la mort
enfin juste après la mort de la mort
elle s'enfuit elle partira à Londres et
effectivement dans les pays du Nord où
elle sera arrêtée par la suite elle est
arrêtée et effectivement elle a rien de
plus à dire mais c'est peut-être là où
il faut raconter des choses un peu
croustillantes je ne vais pas le dire là
parce que nous sommes enregistrés je
peux le dire en conférence faudra venir
nous suivre
le le
à l'époque la question ordinaire est
extraordinaire pour faire avouer les
gens puisqu'effectivement depuis le
décret du village Cauterets on ne peut
plus se contenter de l'intime conviction
donc
il faut laver il faut obtenir un aveu
question ordinaire et comment on obtient
comment on obtient la veuve à la tour
bon bec qui n'a rien à voir avec les
bonbons mais c'est la tour de la bonne
question en fait c'est à Paris là pour
le coup c'est pas à Versailles c'est à
Paris c'est la plus vieille tour du
Palais de la Cité c'est la toute
crénelée et c'est là où se dérouleront
aussi certains procès avec fou qui est
un ville l'accusateur public au moment
de la Révolution française revenons à
Versailles en effet effectivement même
si finalement l'affaire des poisons se
passe essentiellement à Paris quand même
il faut le rappeler alors question
ordinaire extraordinaire je vais vous
citer un exemple à marquise de
Brinvilliers va être effectivement
soumise au supplice de l’eau
c'est-à-dire que le principe est d'avoir
la tête en dessous de l'estomac et de
faire avaler de l'eau vous allez me dire
une vidéo par jour non non là on est
plutôt entre 15 et 18 litres l'été voilà
c'est pour ça que la marquise de
bravilliers qui était on dit une toute
petite un petit bout de bonne femme
ravissante comme tout les seules images
qu'on a d'elle c'est après
c'est pendant le procès où elle est
toute gonflée plus très très jolie et
donc non plus et surtout là quand on
vous l'a fait ingurgiter terme pas très
joli et donc effectivement elle va
avouer et c'est là où il faut
effectivement évoquer ok elle avoue donc
elle va être exécutée mais souvenez-vous
sous l'Ancien Régime suivant à quel
ordre l'on appartient la noblesse le
clergé le tiers état est-ce que l'on a
fait on n'est pas exécuté de la même
façon mais là on est embêté la marquise
de Brinvilliers
oublié de dire quelque chose je le dirai
après mais la marque que j'aimerais bien
est noble donc elle a la chance d'avoir
le droit d'avoir la tête coupée dans la
guillotine n'existe pas encore avec une
épée de justice oui mais là touché des
poisons donc c'est une hérétique c'est
une sorcière donc elle a le droit d'être
brûlée donc en gros on est à Paris elle
est condamnée elle va passer devant
notre Dame amende honorable et elle sera
effectivement exécutée
place de Grève qui n'est autre que la
place de l'hôtel de ville actuelle voilà
la voisin qui a trempé dans la dans la
suite qui est une sorcière
on va pas raconter tout mais finalement
c'est le début de la fin on se dit ça y
est elle est exécutée on ne va plus rien
entendre parler et c'est là où
finalement les autres procès vont
continuer et voilà la Voisin juste un
mot c'est à dire que s'il a fait repris
autour d'ampleur c'est que elle remonte
jusqu'au roi par la montée faire la
montée se pense c'est à dire qu'un jour
en gros vous avez la marquise de
Brinvilliers puis vous avez la voisin
qui est effectivement
c'est une avorteuse à la base c'est une
avorteuse on a retrouvé dans son
quartier parisien 2500 ah bah on a
retrouvé les fœtus oui dans le côté peur
à gouttant on en a retrouvé à Paris
voilà oui non non c'est et effectivement
elle va faire des filtres d'amour mais
elle va aussi faire ce qu'on appelait
des des des des des filtres de
succession parce que c'était trop lent
donc on se débarrassait la première
vidéo c'est quand même débarrassé de son
père de de ses frères de ses sœurs elle
a tenté le mari parce que il y avait
aucune trace quoi alors on en revient à
ce que l'on disait
alors on en revient à ce que l'on disait
antenne finalement il y a trois éléments
pourquoi est-ce qu'on tue pour le
pouvoir pour l'argent par amour et vous
pouvez prendre n'importe quelle affaire
encore aujourd'hui vous aurez toujours
cela comme d'habitude
aussi sur des enquêtes de police qui ont
eu lieu voilà alors on se base en fait
où est-ce que l'on va chercher les
sources parce que c'est bien de faire le
côté très romanesque mais derrière il y
a quand même des vues humaines en jeu
donc les affaires alors vous pouvez
avoir des meurtres
j'avoue que je surnomme souvent cette
visite meurt traversaille parce que
c'est le côté très versaillait et je me
dis on va choquer mais donc il va y
avoir des morts si vous voulez qu'on en
reparle il y a pas de souci mais il y a
aussi des faits divers par exemple et
c'est peut-être là où il faut évoquer
une toute petite chose n'oubliez pas
qu'à Versailles construit au départ le
premier château c'est Louis XIII
complètement privé Louis XIV arrive
là-dessus on pourrait se dire il
installe la cour et le siège du
gouvernement ça devient public j'utilise
les termes contemporains bien évidemment
c'est pas si simple que ça c'est à dire
que tout ce qui touche au roi ça va être
une instance qui s'appelle la prévôté
aujourd'hui la prévôté si vous disc avec
des militaires il vous diront mais il
existe encore une prévôté la prévôté
gérait la cour et tout ce qui se passait
autour lorsque la cour était itinérante
mais elle reste à Versailles après
l'installation mais par contre dans la
ville tout ce qui va se passer par
exemple là je dans les faits divers vous
me dites quel est le parcours on part de
la place d'Armes ensuite on va parler de
l'affaire de Damien devant les petits
appartements Louis XV on se dirige vers
la place Hoche pour effectivement
continuer vers la jauge ou aujourd'hui
c'est le magnifique quartier des
antiquaires c'était beaucoup moins
habitat et c'est surtout la place du
marché et à ce niveau là effectivement
place du marché dit des gens qui boivent
un peu trop des messieurs qui protègent
leurs femmes des gens qui partent sans
payer leur note et
ainsi ils peuvent protéger leur femme
c'est-à-dire que s'il y en a il y a un
voisin qui est un peu aviné embête
pas que tous les hommes se baladent avec
une arme sur c'est vraiment le militaire
mais on a beaucoup de faits divers sur
la place du marché entre celui qui vend
son vin sans payer la taxe le
l'aubergiste enfin plutôt le client vous
avez lu les rapports de police les
rapports de police on se rend compte des
médecins qui n'arrêtent pas de soigner
des plaies on en a une fois que je vous
la raconte elle est très drôle on passe
au passage rapidement
passage Saint-Pierre un moment donné
vous avez un bourgeois qui passe et puis
qui se prend alors j'ai toujours un peu
de chambre en fait c'était les huiles
usées sur la tête procès et ben c'est la
dame qui c'est le bourgeois qui va
perdre pourquoi parce que la domestique
avait crié gare et le bon choix ne
s'était pas poussé voilà c'est mignon
alors passons maintenant au procès qui
ont eu lieu dans la cour d'assis de de
Versailles et il y a un
dont il faut parler c'est celui de Zola
dans
j'allais dire dommage collatéral de
l'affaire Dreyfus
c'est le deuxième procès de Zola qui va
effectivement se dérouler à Versailles
alors vous allez dire mais pourquoi
alors on rappelle qu'effectivement
l'affaire Dreyfus a secoué cette
troisième République et qu'en effet il y
a les antidersfusards les dreyfusards
qui ont beaucoup changé de camp
d'ailleurs si on regarde là je résume je
n'ai pas le choix mais c'est extrêmement
intéressant d'aller creuser la faire et
puis un moment donné Zola est coute au
départ où il fait bon ok c'est une
affaire communauté et puis il entend il
entend des présidents qui se battent et
et il se dit il faut que je me batte
aussi donc il va voir le responsable
directeur de l'aurore effectivement il
va écrire le fameux j'accuse il sait
qu'il va être condamné pour diffamation
parce que dedans il attaque il attaque
tout ce qu'il veut
se remettra jamais en cause lui son but
c'est on fait mon procès mais il dira à
son avocat ne me défendez pas mais
essayez toujours de remettre sur place
de remettre en place de reparler de
l'affaire Dre parce que la
réhabilitation n'est pas encore là on
est à la fin du 19e siècle on est en
1898 99 et en effet donc il y a un
premier procès qui a lieu à Paris il le
fait casser deuxième procès ici pourquoi
parce qu'on pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
monde qui va aller à Paris donc
Versailles les gens ne viendront pas en
fait il y a le train il y a déjà des
trains il y a déjà des gares à
Versailles elles existent depuis une
minute du 19e siècle et en fait tout le
monde va venir Versailles alors il est
condamné à Versailles il est condamné à
la prison et je sais plus je crois que
c'est 3000 francs après le deuxième
procès il attendra pas il s'enfuira à
Londres donc pas celui-ci qui va finir
en prison il part à Londres et il ne
reviendra qu'au moment où il y a le
début de la réhabilitation de Dreyfus
mais le procès en effet a lieu ici avec
mais tous les journalistes qui étaient
là il y a pas que les Versailles et donc
le procès Zola c'est ça c'était arrivé à
attaquer puisque il y a des gens de
l'état-major qui notamment Picard qui ne
comprend pas et voilà voilà et juste car
le défaut arrive aujourd'hui change de
conseil ce Zola a probablement été
assassiné alors on est le 29 septembre
1902 c'est presque presque 120 ans à 121
ans
oui on sait qu'il est mort parce qu'il y
avait la
cheminée
et vous vous pensez alors que c'est
qu'il pense c'est-à-dire qu'au départ
effectivement
quelques années en fait on sait qu'au
moment où il meurt donc il revient de sa
campagne avec sa femme et effectivement
il demande à ce qu'on allume le feu de
cheminée un peu avant pile domestique se
rend compte à le majordome se rend
compte étire mal donc il pense avoir
éteint il ne l'appareil éteint le
lendemain les domestiques n'ont pas de
nouvelles de leur maître ça les inquiète
il frappe il frappe il frappe madame
Zola est effectivement évanoui elle se
réveillera Zola est mort
donc là et dans le le compte-rendu il y
a marqué dans la marge mort accidentel
mais plus de 20 ans après vous avez
effectivement un maçon qui va
effectivement dire un pharmacien
et qui va dire c'est nous en fait nous
avons bouché la cheminée et le temps
qu'on évacue le corps de Zola on a eu le
temps de la déboucher parce qu'il y a
des essais qui vont être faits on va
mettre des oiseaux on va mettre des
chiens il y en a qui meurent il y en a
qui se réveillent on dit on ne peut pas
tuer un homme uniquement avec ça et il
attendra plus de 20 ans et même le
pharmacien attendra encore plus de 20
ans
aujourd'hui faudrait
en effet aujourd'hui
sauf que n'oubliez pas la faire Dreyfus
à l'époque aujourd'hui il faut pour ceux
qui la connaissent faut éviter aussi
d'en parler à un repas ça décore pour
ceux qui connaissent l'affaire
oubliez jamais que Dreyfus qui est
libéré va effectivement au départ la
femme de Zola dit ne venait pas assister
à l'enterrement de mon mari parce que
elle a peur d'un déchaînement de foule
et finalement elle dira il s'est battu
pour vous venez et au moment où Zola est
mis au Panthéon
Dreyfus se fait tirer dessus donc voilà
dernière affaire qu'on va aborder puis
après on va parler de alors on saute si
je peux dire Londres dans le temps
puisque le procès de 1921 je crois oui
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu ici je sais pas si vous le
savez Gauthier la dernière exécution
publique à l'époque quand quelqu'un
était con la mort était exécuté
publiquement le public pouvait venir et
j'ai dû le savoir
17 juin
alors qui était on disait l'assassin ou
visage poupin enfin
d'accord c'était un très très joli
garçon alors lui pour le coup c'est pour
l'argent qui effectivement avait déjà
été condamné
il est déjà il est déjà en maison de
redressement alors je vais en prendre
les termes contemporains en Allemagne il
rencontre des Français en prison en
Allemagne techniquement il n'aurait pas
dû pouvoir venir en France donc être
allemand à la veille de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale c'est pas terrible n'y
voyez aucun propos discriminant mais ça
n'a pas
en France pour cible mais vous êtes
allemand c'est compliqué
effectivement lui c'est vraiment pour
l'argent donc la première ça va être
gêne de Koven qui est une Américaine qui
est une qui est une danseuse américaine
et effectivement il l'a rencontre à
l'hôtel Ambassadeur à Paris boulevard
Haussmann et puis il voit que son
chaperon que sa tante ne pas très
présente donc il l'invite il lui dit
venez et en fait il a loué weimman
alloué une maison à La Celle-Saint-Cloud
là Voulzy
c'est discret donc il va alors là on est
aujourd'hui plus tout à fait d'accord de
la manière dont la danseuse a été tuée
mais il s'avère qu'effectivement l'idée
c'était de la kidnapper et de demander à
la tente un une rançon il va la tuer
extrêmement rapidement la rançon il leur
a jamais totalement sur toutes les
médias s'en mêlent donc il sait que là
il vaut mieux qu'il disparaisse il y a
le l'agent immobilier sera tué il va
tuer un de ces un de ces un de ses
collègues j'allais dire un de ces un de
ces acolytes voilà
il y en avait qu'il avait rencontré en
prison des Français d'autres qui va
aller qui va aller chercher ils sont pas
toujours très sûrs de leur coup on se
rend compte qui tuent souvent pour pas
tant d'argent que cela mais que l'argent
vient très très vite à manquer il va
être effectivement arrêté et c'est la
dernière exécution publique c'est à dire
que elle s'est passé alors les gens je
ne sais pas s'ils seront ou nous sommes
mais juste derrière nous devant
l'ancienne la porte de l'ancienne prison
Saint-Pierre et alors je dis toujours
méfiance si vous tapotez sur Internet
moi je n'ose plus regarder mais il y a
eu alors il y a une vidéo et c'est la
vraie tête qui tombe alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé les exécutions sont
publiques mais normalement très très tôt
le matin avant 4h là qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il y a eu du retard est-ce que la
guillotine on a mis du temps à la monter
est-ce que enfin on ne sait pas mais il
fait jour donc on a des photos prisons
c'est très exactement de quel de quelle
fenêtre elles ont été prises et le
lendemain Daladier
et furieux parce que il dit ça n'est
plus possible à présent les exécutions
auront lieu à dans l'enceinte des
prisons toujours très tôt le matin donc
c'est la dernière exécution publique
nous n'en disons qu'une partie donc
n'hésitez pas vous parler aussi
évidemment vous parlez évidemment aussi
de Landru alors Gauthier on va
évidemment cette pièce elle est tirée de
tout ce qu'on peut savoir du procès
puisque c'est le procès
le titre même de la pièce est une phrase
je n'ai rien de ne rien vous dire
alors d'abord un mot comment comment là
vous allez jouer dans quelques dans
quelques heures vous allez maquiller
chauve brun brun
comment on se met dans la peau d'un
tueur quand on détecteur après tout
c'est le métier mais oui oui
c'est une question
assez complexe je pense que chaque
acteur je répondrai différemment je
pense mais
pour Landru en tout cas il y avait déjà
de la préparation vraiment en amont du
rôle de super peu de la lecture le
document puis beaucoup de discussions
avec le metteur en scène avec Louis
Barou pour avoir son son cloche sur
comment il perçoit l'andru comment il
veut montrer l'andru dans la pièce donc
donc beaucoup de travail psychologique
de discussions pour savoir ok alors là
il faut que je parce qu'il y a quand
même un espèce de double jeu en jouant
en russe qui selon notre version en tout
cas enfin selon
avoir tout un chacun mais pour moi en
tout cas était coupable mais jouait là
non culpabilité donc il y a un espèce de
double jeu
Landru qui se dit innocent mais qui ne
l'est pas enfin il y a un espèce de
trucs
voilà exactement c'est une espèce de
tradition
formidable à faire et puis en plus de
cette intériorité il y a beaucoup de
répétitions où on va on va un peu voilà
régler chaque petite chose faire du
travail très minutieux sur des phrases
qui sous-entendent que oui mais en fait
que je ne suis pas coupable et tout ça
et puis ensuite évidemment le costume et
dans mon calme maquillage qui est
littéralement à changer de peau en fait
pour le coup vraiment il y a un côté
caméléon de d'enfiler un costume de
d'avoir ce cette espèce de calotte de
calotte sur laquelle on pose une
couronne de cheveux plus un peu plus
deux heures de maquillage voilà deux
heures deux heures et quart de se mettre
dans la peau oh oui carrément il y a un
travail de patience et de matériorité
votre idée comme ça quand maintenant que
vous avez lu vous avez joué le
personnage second c'est un escroc et
c'est un escroc oui ça c'est évident
depuis bien avant de devenir un
meurtrier et au fond c'est pour pas se
faire attraper qui tue ah oui c'est très
terre à terre c'est vrai que quand on
parle de tueur en série
je pense ça nous vient des États-Unis à
mon avis il y a un sous-entendu toujours
psychologique
d'une jouissance exactement Landru
c'était pas du tout beaucoup plus
basique que ça c'est si je tue la femme
que j'ai arnaqué elle va pas me dénoncer
à la police je pense que c'était aussi
simple que ça puisqu'il a commencé sans
les tuer c'est c'est les victimes de ces
arnaques il a commencé sans les tuer et
puis au bout d'un moment ils se sont mis
il essaie d'en prendre sans famille
aussi oui oui mais quand bien même il a
fait de la prison à cause de de
d'arnaque comme ça et on s'est dit avec
Louis Barrault et les autres comédiens
en discutant c'est probable en prison
qui s'est fait bon oui je vais français
mais cette fois je vais essayer de pas
laisser des personnes qui ont parlé
d'être moi voilà donc c'est très terre à
terre je pense c'est ce qui est dit dans
la pièce
de bœuf qui il y a des des faits qui
pèsent afin qu'ils peuvent faire croire
que le culpabilité dont le fait en effet
qu'il prenait un aller-retour pour lui
quand il allait un gambe et un aller
simple de deux allées un seul retour
pour les peuples il accompagnait mais on
n'a pas de preuve très tangible de sa
culpabilité pas réellement le l'un des
trucs qui parlent beaucoup je trouve
c'est le fait très binairement les
meurtres se sont arrêtés après son
exécution après oui il y a les fables le
fameux carnet noir
qui avait dit si si si monsieur le
Président vous le grassiez je le prends
comme secrétaire
et puis il y a il y a pas que le de
aller un retour il y a des scie à métaux
qui ont été achetés
fois par douzaine il y a pas de preuves
absolues il y a pas la preuve même mais
il y a tant de choses qui font dire que
quand même mais après c'est là toute la
question de la pièce la conviction ne
fait pas preuve je dis ça parce que l'un
des entrées de la pièce c'est que alors
il y avait je crois 14 jurés très
bizarrement exceptionnellement c'est 14
juillet au lieu de d'habitude et donc
vous prenez 14 spectateurs
qui vont être après la pièce à le site
de la pièce chargée de de juger l'autre
rue et de le dire est-ce qu'il est
coupable pas coupable vous allez jouer
la pièce à gamber deux fois deux fois
sur lui-même un Saulieu ou la première
fois une fois ici une fois ici vous avez
la rejouer ici elle sera captée
d'ailleurs ce soir parfaitement jusqu'à
on peut dévoiler un peu les jugements
qui qui ont été on peut on peut
parfaitement dévoiler les jugements
alors sur quatre dates on a eu trois
dates où l'andru a été connu coupable
d'arnaque mais non coupable d'assassinat
c'est quand même incroyable et la
quatrième l'une des l'une des dates pour
le coup coupable de toutiné tout ça mais
alors après il y a des choses qui sont
très intéressantes parce qu'on joue la
pièce en 2023 oui alors et voilà
c'est la guillotine alors est-ce que
dans les délibérés avec notre
sensibilité éthique actuelle est-ce que
ils se disent bon on a eu parce que
régulièrement on interagit un peu avec
les spectateurs après la pièce on a eu
beaucoup qui nous ont dit pour moi il
est coupable mais si je dis coupable il
meurt condamner à mort un homme et
d'autres qui dit et d'autres qui disent
vraiment moi je pense que on ne peut pas
statuer sur l'affaire on n'a pas assez
d'éléments maintenant moi si j'étais
spectateur je dis c'est la première fois
que je peux condamner quelqu'un à mort
sans que
ça on n'aura pas l'occasion de revoir on
va pas vous guillotiner pour de vrai
quoi non je préfère pas jusqu'au jusque
là donc la pièce vous cache pas que je
préférerais qu'on évite
un mot voilà le rôle est aussi
extraordinaire parce que
au-delà du tueur de la faire c'est aussi
personnalité qui a un humour très
personnel je peux dire enfin c'est vrai
qu'il y a des bons mots de rue ils ont
couru mais il y avait énormément de
personnalités c'était c'était un
blockbuster ce ce procès quand vous
parliez de de Zola que vous avez fait ça
à Versailles on se disant qu'il y aurait
pas trop de monde au final il y avait
des similarités avec l'andru parce que
tout le monde est venu il y avait les
trains qui avaient été affrêter
spécifiquement pour le pour le Conseil
les trains Landru euh oui
c'était un spectacle mais total c'était
après la Première Guerre mondiale donc
les gens avaient envie de se divertir en
allant voir un procès le procès de
quelqu'un qui faisait son show c'était
un présentateur de talk show américain
absolument tout le monde Moro déjà ferry
c'était
en montée qui était l'un des plus grands
et une superstar l'avocat général donc
en général qui était une superstar le
président Gilbert également ça on essaie
de le montrer dans la pièce ils ont tous
des personnalités très fortes comédiens
dans la pièce alors vous jouez Landru
vous pouvez nous dire à peu près qui
joue quoi bien sûr alors on a romain
pyrosa qui joue qui joue Godefroy donc
l'avocat général voilà on a François
priolly qui joue le président Gilbert
qui ordonne le tout et qui était un
petit peu biaisé un brin on a Margot
Geiger qui joue qui joue Moro déjà fait
rire absolument voilà Louis Barrault qui
va jouer le commissaire Belin qui est
également important
voilà alors oui oui sachant qu'il y
avait un autre policier dans l'équation
quand même mais c'est vrai que pour la
pièce on va essayer de condenser un
petit peu
mais mais Belin a apporté beaucoup de
doutes aussi parce que il y a eu
beaucoup de d'erreurs judiciaires quand
même dans le dans la procédure il y a eu
beaucoup de vis de procédure et on a
ensuite domicile le boeuf qui jouent les
témoins voilà plusieurs euros plusieurs
rôles notamment certaines femmes que
l'on devrait côtoyer certaines proches
des femmes que l'on veut côtoyer la
maîtresse de elle joue également la la
dernière
donc n'est pas morte
dans le procès qui est qui est un témoin
des charges si je peux dire qu'elle est
amoureuse de Landru il faut l'amoureuse
vous pensez que lui aussi amoureux
d'elle
moi je pense que oui c'est un gros on
discute beaucoup de la pièce forcément
dans la troupe et on pense beaucoup que
que l'andru la messe sincèrement quand
même après c'est une interprétation
comme une autre et puis au final c'est
pas très pertinent de savoir ce qu'on
pense
bien sûr
tout à fait mais c'est une thèse tout à
fait plausible enfin
et puis je pense après une histoire qui
est si morbide il y a un côté presque
poétique entre énorme guillemets de se
dire la dernière femme qui n'a pas tué
il en était fou amoureux
dans le dans le procès ou dit après tout
ce qu'on a le qu'on a fait sur mon nom
le regret que j'ai c'est qu'on a appris
à me pauvre femme que je l'avais trompé
on la raconte dans la conférence
c'est fantastique
on peut dire ça on peut dire mais moi je
vous réponds voilà il ne faut pas dire
le le qui commence par un M je voulais
expliquer pourquoi c'est parce qu'il y
avait
à cheval tout à fait et plus il y avait
de merde ça veut dire que plus il y
avait de chevaux donc il pleut il y
avait de public la voilà mais je pense
vous la connaissez la raison j'ai
entendu deux trois autres
interprétations il y en a plusieurs
merde oui voilà on peut dire merde et je
vous réponds je prends avec grand
plaisir
donc on va aller voir le 8 octobre et le
17 décembre ou le 17 décembre tous les
deux on peut faire les deux de toute
façon c'est assez régulier voilà chaque
conférence qui est là-bas la manière et
en effet une façon
très originale de visiter Versailles et
d'aborder d'autres thématiques voilà
tout à l'heure on parlait de guillotine
mais on n'ira pas non mais l'histoire de
la vie le Versailles
oui c'est passé quand même beaucoup de
choses sur le plan merci merci
infiniment aussi et merci
alors pour terminer cette émission gros
plan sur la troupe qui va qui va jouer
je n'ai rien à vous dire la pièce sur
l'autre avec Louis Barrault vous êtes le
montant en scène et puis l'auteur de
cette pièce tout à fait mais co-auteur
ce qu'il y a absolument il est nage
aussi qui a eu sa part d'écriture
également absolument et c'est alors on
va parler avec vous mais c'est une belle
aventure quand même ah oui une très
belle aventure on s'attendait pas
atterrir à la cour d'assises de
Versailles endroit historique ou Landru
a été emprisonné jugé et décapité et
décapités
[Musique]
dehors et dans le tribunal mais elle a
été détruite quand ils ont fait les
travaux de rénovation du tribunal voilà
donc quand je dis belle en voiture c'est
à dire que l'aventure a commencé à
Saulieu après agrobé dans la ville ou
Landry avait sa maison ça ça continue
ici dans la cour d'assise vous allez
revenir d'ailleurs à gamber oui le 18
novembre effectivement le samedi 18
novembre à 20h il me semble il y a déjà
des de réservation donc ça marche du feu
pour l'instant on joue à guichet fermé
depuis sa 4e date ce soir on est à
guichet fermé donc c'est c'est vraiment
inespéré et puis on va parler avec
Gauthier tout à l'heure évidemment il y
a cette pour vous je pense que ça change
aussi c'est à dire que il y a le des
jurés qui se réunissent et donc c'est à
chaque fois c'est une pièce nouvelle
quoi on ne sait jamais moi je ne parie
plus avec eux sur le sort de nombreuses
qu'à chaque fois je perds voilà
mais oui effectivement les jurés nous
surprennent on s'attendait à Versailles
à avoir un un verdict différent disons
on est à Versailles là où il a été jugé
d'égalité on s'est dit bah ils vont le
reconnaître coupable et bien non
mais une fois sur deux euh
il a pour l'instant non coupable meurtre
donc coupable de meurtre on verra bien
ce qui va se passer surprise alors un
mot avec vous alors vous êtes président
oui tout à fait oui présent
alors moi c'est François prioli voilà
donc c'est moi qui vais présider cette
audience avec Landru en accusé donc
c'est un grand moment encore ce soir je
ne sais pas quelle va être le verdict
vous serez vous serez très objectif ah
oui tout à fait moi d'une grande
objectivité de par ma fonction et est-ce
que est-ce que ferry vous vous énerve un
peu
Moro j'ai fait un petit peu alors j'ai
un droit de enfin je me dois de d'être
sur la réserve je n'ai pas le droit de
le dire mais voilà un peu une tête qui
me revient pas alors maître moradjafiri
c'est jouer par une femme un actrice
au féminin peut-être pour ça que
j'énerve monsieur on ne sait pas
l'avocat
c'est très très intéressant moi à chaque
fois chaque fois qu'on la joue je suis
mais c'est un énorme plaisir quoi c'est
je vais pas dire ça
trois heures de la représentation vous
avez un peu le chocottes non
moi j'ai pas encore eu le temps d'y
penser mais
je pense que oui quand le public va
s'installer là ça va venir en fait
samedi dernier on le stress
ah non non nous on est chacun nos places
en fait voilà j'ai donc Margot qui joue
mon Roger féri et Romain qui joue
l'avocat général Godefroy qui sont en
fait non toi tu fais une entrée mais ma
Margaux en fait l'installation
[Musique]
excusez-moi je dis des bêtises en fait
tout le monde rentre un peu après le
public mais il y a oui voilà
20 ans il a le droit de dire ce qu'il
veut
j'ai le droit de dire ce qu'il veut et
puis peut-être qu'il a tout changé oui
en fait je voulais pas dit mais on a
changé beaucoup de choses pour ce soir
voilà c'est ça je vous préviendrai à
20h55 alors l'avocat général
vous êtes contents parce que vous vous
demandez la mort à chaque fois oui après
vous l'obtenez parfois pas toujours
ça malheureusement
faut y aller un petit peu plus et
pourtant j'y vais et pourtant j'y vais
vraiment je donne de la personne et puis
en plus de ça j'ai la chance de pouvoir
être en hauteur chose qui a jamais été
faite parce que à chaque fois qu'on
jouait au théâtre ou quoi que ce soit et
toujours à la même hauteur
au niveau de la vérité voilà c'est ça et
d'être en hauteur comme ça sur le bureau
c'est déjà ça change énormément de
choses et même sur la mise en scène sur
les déplacements oui est-ce que ça
change beaucoup de jouer dans une vraie
dans un vrai tribunal énormément
énormément
de de je dirais d'émotions parce qu'il y
a c'est un tribunal en ordre de marche
donc qui a régulièrement des audiences
dans cette salle et effectivement c'est
vrai que c'est ça fait quelque chose
qu'on s'assoit
moi dans le box réservé aux policiers
François assurance
voilà grâce on va faire des exercices
grâce à son insistance a réussi et de
fait à mettre la rue derrière des
barreaux ce qui a été
compliqué au début voilà et puis il y a
une actrice qui fait tous les rôles
exactement
et je fais tous les rôles des témoins
voilà plus la maîtresse de Landru alors
oui mais qui est une témoin
c'est une témoin en effet mais comme on
le disait avec GOTY Jean-Pierre tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que elle est très
amoureuse de lui c'est ça et d'ailleurs
elle elle est sur une d'abord
mais oui Fernand de Fernand de secret
qui d'ailleurs dit bien être la fiancée
de Landru mais comme une autre une autre
témoin que je fais qui s'appelle
mademoiselle blanc qui elle aussi penser
à la fiancée de l'andrue
finalement
on prend et c'est vrai que c'est bon
voilà une très belle aventure et puis
je pense elle va continuer encore
pendant pas mal de temps c'est pas
évident à ce que vous faites
c'est-à-dire que vous jouez pas non plus
tous les soirs c'est c'est là c'est une
semaine entre les représentations elle
arrive à faire 18 novembre après c'est
il faut se remettre dans les rôles il
faut reprendre l'énergie c'est c'est un
vrai boulot quoi
avec le général toujours pour se
remettre dedans et pour y aller à fond
voilà chaque fois on trouve quelque
chose de nouveau à apporter ou quelque
chose à modifier ou pour continuer ce ce
je viens pas se perfectionnement mais
cette évolution du spectacle bravo bravo
parce que c'est voilà c'était la pièce
que tout le monde attendait au fond et
c'est très bien d'avoir fait on espère
on espère tueur en série cours d'assises
et je pense que les gens sont assez
curieux de voir ce que ça rend dans un
vrai décor et puis ils peuvent juger et
ils peuvent juger exactement très
important et on a reçu des mails nous
nous demandons de truquer le tirage au
sort pour que les gens soient sûr d'être
juste
un petit peu d'argent non
mais faut pas le dire
je vous laisse parce que bah voilà faut
leur laisser concentrer il y a la
représentation en plus il y a la
captation ce soir donc c'est tout va
bien merci
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]